would it be possible um to hit a few
headlines with one of my favorite og
daily show correspondents
go for it let's see what do you got well
all right actually i'm going to give you
the first coat all right um oh here we
go
so a story from the bbc and you know how
credit cards now have that little
contactless chip right so you don't need
to swipe you can just tap your card you
don't need to swipe right so now you can
get that implanted in your hand
the chip is the size of a grain of rice
and is encased in
biopolymer and you hold your hand over a
sensor and boop your bill is paid
you can freak out your waitresses paying
with your hand now that is priceless
right
i don't know i don't like this one but
you know like that that terrible
nightmare when you're at an auction and
you wave at a friend and you just bought
a painting yeah imagine you just walk by
beep bop boo that's what i'm worried
about i think this is going to be a
problem you go you could walk through
bed bath and beyond and come out with a
six thousand dollar bill because you
talk with your hands yes
you know i just don't know i don't like
it the only chip i want in my hand is a
pringle thank you very much
no thank you
i do have the watch though where i can
like pay just like a double deep boop
and that's easy right so maybe they
could do a ring or something but the
difference is you can take your watch
off yes exactly and a ring i'm into that
that's cute right yeah it's a payment
ring
yeah
i own it
i'm just kidding
copyright all right hey next up a
british group called uk antarctic
heritage trust
they're looking for three people to run
the most remote post office in the world
in antarctica yeah travel leisure
reports the job runs november through
march which is apparently the you know
the best season in antarctica and ideal
candidates must enjoy adventure be
willing to count penguins for an ongoing
penguin study be okay with absolutely no
internet or cell service and a small
thing there are no showers or running
water all right so
is the running no running water because
it would just freeze is that what's
going on and like also then like then
what then what where do we go from there
how do we
be hygienic
gross i'm not moving to antarctica
there's only like two people down there
so it's not like you know right like the
penguins are like
well speaking of animals we have news
from arizona where a wild javelina got
stuck in a hatchback after it went
looking for cheese puffs the owners left
the hatchback open overnight and the
javelina sniffed out the cheesy snack
but his weight closed the door behind
him so he chewed off part of the dash
and part of the door and he knocked the
car into neutral and ended up across the
street by morning no one was hurt
including the hungry hungry javelina and
the local sheriff's office has issued a
reminder to residents quote
don't feed the javelina
i will say this javelina looks like me
in my kitchen at night
like crashing
cheesy snacks everywhere i relate to
this javelina i'm like i i like that's
so bad for this javelina like the poor
thing that was going on after the cheap
why would you leave cheese puffs in your
car and the door open if you live
in an area that has these pig rodents
running around
i mean don't you think like well i can
tell you with certainty this would never
happen to me because i would never leave
cheese puffs girl i'm eating all of
those that that's not happening to me uh
since monday
can you come back yeah i'll come back
whenever you want really yeah i want to
do this with you more often let's do it
okay great well watch episodes of would
i lie to you every saturday on the cw
and watch asif in the new show evil
seasons one and two now streaming on
paramount plus and season three is out
june 12th because that show is huge
people love we have we have crazy fans
on that crazy fan it's it's it's it's
good it's a lot of fun so happy for all
your success
a game show daily show come on and
and you can still watch music and lyrics
it's still out there
[Music]